questions so hello everybody welcome to
station 18 of igcs to 2020 about
algorithms
so we will have five presentations uh in
this session the first one will be uh
only about probing to minimize so in
general
feel free to go
thanks for the introduction
um i'm jalani i'm a fourth year phd
student at cmu and i'm here to talk
about probing to minimize a project on
stochastic probing which is joint work
with my advisor uh wong and anupam gupta
so i've been told that it's best to
start things off with a concrete example
so i'll be doing just that
imagine you're building a cool
pool and you need a high quality bag of
concrete so you go to the hardware store
and you see what's available
it turns out there are two concrete
brands available at the store a trusted
brand and a risky brand
now you'll recall that i said we want a
high quality bag of concrete and we'll
measure that quality in kind of a
negative way uh each bag will have an
independently random number of defects
where the number of where the
distribution of defects depends on the
brand so for example the custard brand
has
effects distributed this way and the
risky brand has defects distributed this
way
now naturally each brand also prices
their bags differently the trusted bag
costs 100 while the risky brand costs
twenty dollars so even the problem is
given that you have a budget of 100
um and your goal is to minimize the
expected number of defects in your best
bag of concrete what should you do
well what can we do in this case we
actually only have two options we can
either buy one trusted bag or buy five
risky bags right and and the expectation
is actually pretty easy to compute in
this case
if we want to trust it back then the
expected number of defects is 3.5
whereas if we buy five risky bags and
take the best one our expected um
number of defects is one okay and so in
this case we actually gain something
from taking all of these risks so now
that we have that concrete example in
our minds let's go to the formal setting
um so in general this is going to be a
dynamic set selection problem so uh let
me just like say that we'll call our
selection set s right and we'll be
choosing the selection set s from a
universe u
of indifferent element and for each of
those elements we're going to associate
a random weight which takes values in
the integers from zero to m okay and so
why do we have that i'll talk a little
bit more about why we have that
restriction later um
so we're choosing our set s and our goal
is to minimize the expected value of
some objective function f which depends
on which is some function of the weights
in s right and write that as f of s with
the understanding that you know the
weights there are implicit
so we can't just choose any set that we
want we also have a collection of
feasible sets that we can use uh script
f and we'll require this collection to
be subset closed
so for example this could be like a
knapsack constraint or a metroid
constraint or anything like that
okay so again our goal is to minimize
the expected value of this function
subject to constraint that our final set
is within this feasible set
and we also need to distinguish between
two different settings here
the adaptive setting and the
non-adaptive in the adaptive setting we
build our selection set element by
element and as we add an element to our
set its random weight is revealed and we
can then adapt our strategy based on it
right
whereas for the non-adaptive setting uh
we have to choose our selection set all
at once and information is revealed at
the end okay
right so now that we have a formal model
um you know what's known about uh what's
known about this and and
the preface will be focusing on adaptive
uh on the adaptive setting here okay so
what's known for adaptive maximization
okay uh
you can think of it as like a beautiful
bountiful fourth like there are a ton of
results for adaptive max
adaptive maximization whereas for
minimization like it's more like a
desert not much is known even for some
very basic effective functions um for
example if we take our function to be
the minimum weight element in s like
really really nothing is known about the
adaptive case
so what about what about the
non-adaptive case well everything we
know is from one paper from huell guha
and monogala in 2010 called how to probe
for an extreme value
in in that paper they give results for
the non-adaptive problem
and they show that it's actually np hard
to approximate um
like the objective value within a polyam
factor without you know sort of
softening our budget constraint and so
we really need to be able to go over
budget in order to approximate as well
okay and so along with that hardness
result they give an algorithmic result
they give a non-adaptive algorithm uh
which is epsilon close to the
non-adaptive optimum and which uses like
log log m times the budget okay
now uh
they also left adaptive approximation as
sort of a challenging open problem in
this paper and that's what we're going
to focus on here
and so one simple question that one
might ask is is it possible to kind of
close the loop and say okay the
non-adaptive optimum is close to the
adaptive optimum no it turns out we
there's there are examples where the
adaptive optimum is arbitrarily smaller
than the non-adaptive oxygen
and so you really need new techniques
here okay
what's what's the main difficulty in
finding these approximations
uh well
in particular why is the adaptive case
so much harder than the non-adaptive
case uh well
we think that it comes down really to
the optimal structure of the problem um
in particular like if we look at the
non-adaptive optimal policy it's just
some set it's possibly a difficult set
compute but it's just some set at the
end of the day whereas in the adaptive
case in general the optimal adaptive
policy is some
very decision tree uh where m is the
number of possible values that a random
variable can take on right and so we
there's a decision tree that sort of
depends on every single weight outcome
right
and so you might ask why isn't this an
issue for maximization and that's
because
uh actually
maximization it seems like you don't
need to be as concerned with what's
happening in all of the decision tree
because in the failure cases like things
sort of happen
in a nicer way so let me be more
specific
say
when we're doing maximization arguments
we can usually say just like for example
in the green part of this decision tree
like something good happens and we with
like reasonable probability like get
something close to the optimal objective
value in this case right
and any case where you know something
good doesn't happen we can just say oh
we get no objective value in that case
and we'll be fine right
whereas
when it comes to minimization actually
we're very concerned about what happens
in in these works cases because often
that can be the source of most of our
expected value right so we can't just
ignore that we can't just chalk it up to
we can't just get like this factor in
there right so how do we get around this
difficulty
we use a technique that we call
thresholding and doing this we can avoid
thinking about mary decision trees
entirely we can focus entirely we can
focus totally on binary decision trees
but the catches they they're the optimal
decision trees for an adaptive
probability minimization problem right
and you know i i might be scaring you
saying that we're going to do adaptive
probability minimization but uh let's go
through an example of why that's not
actually that scary right
so intuition for what we call threshold
problems let's go back to our concrete
example
um
what if instead of wanting to minimize
our expected number of defects in our
best bag we just said okay
if if it has fewer than five defects
then it's good enough right
and now that we've said that fewer than
five defects is good enough let's just
try to minimize the probability that our
final bag has more than five defects
right this five is going to be our
threshold
and this this problem is our threshold
problem
okay and you'll see this really kind of
transforms our problem because now
whereas before we were concerned about
like all the m different uh possible
values that a random variable could take
on now we're really concerned only about
one thing is it smaller than or greater
than five defects right and so this can
this basically turns our random variable
which in general is very complex into a
bernoulli random variable or a coin flip
okay
and so we can we can do this and say we
succeed say we get something that's that
has fewer than five defects what if
after that we shoot for something that
has fewer than two defects and what if
we continue this process right um we'll
show two things about continuing this
process right uh the first thing we do
is we tell that you actually can
approximate some of these threshold
problems well and i won't go into how
but you can see that in the paper um the
second thing we show is that you choose
the right thresholds and you stop at the
right lines actually gives you a fairly
good adaptive approximation
okay and so the results we get are we
close that open problem that i mentioned
before and we're also able to deal with
a generalization of it where instead of
looking at the smallest weight in s we
look at the sum of the smallest k
weights mass and we get similar
approximations um now the threshold
problem in this generalization is a lot
more difficult but you know after after
some work you can you can approximate it
um so besides this in our paper an
archive version we eat other
other variant and i think we're probably
out of about out of time right now um
so i'm just gonna
thank our funding sources and open the
floor for questions
yeah please feel free to mute yourself
or leave your question in the chat box
so let me ask one question generally i
just wonder like a so um so you
mentioned like uh
so so that the approximation algorithm
[Music]
has to violate the constraint a
polynomial factor otherwise you get no
customer approximation but
is that a long log m term necessary or
like uh we can we can expand something
better
so
we we've been wondering the same thing
right especially since we get the same
like log log in factor both
well like guha go hell and monogala they
got that log log n factor and then we
got in our adaptive approximation for an
entirely different reason that same log
log n factor so like it's
we're definitely wondering the same
thing whether there's some kind of
fundamental barrier of log log m or not
but we we don't really have any idea of
how to approach it
okay thank you yeah we got one question
in the child box can you see it
uh
yeah
i start the fact that my problems are a
lot harder to understand than my
experience
to appear in other areas
yeah yeah
it's definitely a common thing
along a lot of areas minimization is
just harder than maximization all the
time
um
yeah we have uh
okay maybe uh
maybe that's all uh
generally okay
okay
okay so
okay so
the next talk will be
okay
so any channel do you want to share your
screen yeah
okay
okay so
let me make the introduction so hello
everybody so uh
the next talk will be by alexander
in the mail about double coverage with
machine learned otherwise okay on the
channel please feel free to come
yeah thank you very much hi i'm alex i'm
from the university of grim in germany
and i will present you joy and work
with nicole mego and bertrosimo
and the goal of this presentation is to
give you an idea on how we can improve a
very classic um online algorithm for a
very fundamental problem using machine
learning predictions
so first let me introduce a problem
which is the online case server problem
on the line
so let's consider some real line
and the first part of the input is a
initial server configuration which tells
us where our k servers are located in
the in the beginning
so in this example here we have just two
servers located at c
then the second part of the input is a
sequence of n requests of points on this
line which arrive one by one meaning in
the beginning the an algorithm just sees
the first request
and it first has to serve it by moving
one server to the request and then it
sees the next request
and so on so the algorithms always
decide how to solve the
requests and the goal is to serve our
requests by minimizing the total travel
distance over the whole instance
and we analyze an
online algorithm using the framework of
competitive analysis where we say that
an algorithm is alpha competitive if we
can bound its cost by alpha times the
cost of the optimal solution um
for for all instances and the optimal
solution has of course access to all the
requests and not bonds
so it is known that any deterministic
algorithm is at least k competitive for
the
online case of our problem on any metric
space and therefore also on the real
line
but on the line there actually exists a
very nice and classic algorithm called
double coverage which is
which achieves this optimal um
competitive ratio of k
and it works as follows so whenever a
new request appears
um it moves the at most two closest
servers of the request
um towards the request with the same
speed
and stops both
when one of them served to request
so this means that the closest server
will eventually solve the request and we
server we our closest server on the
other side will move the same distance
okay now our goal is to design a
learning augmented online algorithm for
the online case or problem in a line
so what we have seen so far is a online
problem with some online input sequence
of requests and we've also seen a
classic online algorithm like double
coverage
which solves
this problem and this algorithm has a
competitive ratio means it
which means that it is robust against
any input
but the thing is well it maybe performs
poorly on easy instances or in special
scenarios like in scenarios where for
example an online input appears on a
daily basis
very could actually use a machine
learned model which we could train on
this online input to gain some
prediction on a solution or on the
online input
so this could give us valuable
information but we have no guarantee but
this
information is really good
because for example on one day there
could be a completely different online
input
so the idea of learning organic online
algorithms is to combine the best out of
both worlds here
meaning that we give the algorithm a
prediction of a certain quality but we
also use a classic robust methods
and
yeah there are two
two special performance indicators which
are interesting the first one is
consistency
and this is really the case where we
assume but the algorithm gets a really
good prediction a perfect prediction
and
so we say about a eyewitness either
consistent if it is either competitive
for this case and this alpha should be
really low so we really want to benefit
from having good predictions
but on the other side we also want that
our algorithm
is still robust against any input
meaning
it should be better competitive for any
prediction
so this is a very
successful framework
and a very
active research area and they're like
coming daily results for
various online problems but also in
other areas of online optimization
okay and now
we want to apply this framework to our
problem
so let's first define a prediction model
and
our prediction model gives us for every
request
a corresponding a server which should
serve the request so when a new request
arrives the prediction model tells us
they'll use this server to serve this
request or use that server to serve to
request
and based on this prediction
we can define a very simple algorithm
which just follows the prediction
right so
if there are a new if a new request
arrives
and some server on the left which isn't
circuit print here is predicted we just
move the closest server which is on the
same side as predicted server to serve
the request
so this means that this algorithm fully
trusts the prediction and if the
prediction is correct so if we kind of
predict an optimal solution
um we also follow the optimal solution
meaning that we are one consistent
but there are instances and predictions
where this is just a bad idea and we get
an unbounded competitive ratio so we are
not robust
but we've also seen another album
namely double coverage so if you have w
if you give double coverage a predicted
server
it will just ignore it so it doesn't
trust the prediction at all and just
does it it's a usual stuff
and since it is k competitive we know
that it is k consistent and k robust
and now what we eventually want is an
algorithm where we can set our level of
trust so we want to set how much we
actually trust the prediction
and our solution to this question is
that we can balance with trust using
different server speeds
and we came up with an algorithm which
we call lambda dc which works as follows
so whenever a new request arrives
we move the server which is on the same
side as predicted server with speed one
but we server on the other side with a
lower speed lambda where lumber is our
hyper parameter which is a value between
0 and 1 which expresses our trust into
the prediction
so if we set lambda to 0 our algorithm
just does the same as just following the
prediction
which means that we fully trust the
prediction but if we set lambda to one
our algorithms just be same as static
coverage
and yeah for all numbers in between we
kind of interpolate between both
and
yeah we can see this also in our
theoretical results for this algorithm
namely we prove that this algorithm has
a competitive ratio of at most
alpha k which is the consistency ratio
times one plus the
quality of the prediction
divided by the cost of an optimal
solution so this term just gets worse as
the prediction gets worse
and we robustness ratio
so let's look at how these concepts look
like
um
so for only having two servers our i
roof is one plus lambda consistent
and one plus one over lambda
robust
so our
consistency really interpolates between
the consistency of following the
prediction which is one
and double coverage which is two
depending on lambda and the same goes
for robustness um we are too robust for
lambda equal to one and as lambda gets
smaller your business just explodes
and yeah this generalizes also to
general values of k
where we can get this expression for the
consistency which is for example for
k equals four this is one plus two
lambda lambda squared
and yeah we rust this is just um
we sum over the flip powers of lambda
so this is consistency robustness and we
also have
um different error definitions which
look as follows
yeah which essentially just compare the
cost between
followed a prediction and an optimal
solution so that's how we measure
our prediction
and further results of our work are a
best possible consistency robustness
trade-off among all memoryless
algorithms
satisfy a
locality property which means that any
memoryless algorithm which
is
in range of a factor 2
of our consistency
has to have have at least um few
robustness of our eye
this is a kind of lower bound
and we also
validated our theoretical findings and
empirical experiments which really show
that
for example if you compare the
green lines here which are the lines
where we just fully trust the prediction
um so here we can see that the
performance really gets worse as the
prediction gets worse
but if you just add a little bit of
non-trust like setting lambda to 0.1
um our algorithm
so performs really well um even for a
large prediction error
yes so thank you very much and now i'm
happy to answer your questions
maybe i have one question uh so so you
uh so in this slide you mentioned like
this is uh the best possible uh
trade-off up to
a fact of two uh for the for some
locality properties can you
yeah bear out what is the locality
property
yeah so this
yeah i think for the question um yeah
this is a mainly a technical assumption
um for our lower bound
and
we call this property locally consistent
and this requires um an algorithm to be
um to have a good performance for a sub
instance which it just serves on a
certain subset of servers so if it just
uses a certain subset of servers
it should
have the corresponding compa consistency
ratio um depending on this number of
servers for a certain part of the
instance
i see quality
yeah we also hope we also have one
question in the child box uh
so it's by omar wisman so
he wonder if the results or in science
can be generalized to general matrix
matrices
um yes thank you for the question um
yeah so we have some
intuition on how this similar i group
may work for tree metrics
because there are also double coverage
algorithm um sk competitive
but for general metrics um
yeah i'm not really sure how this speed
speed
could help maybe types
for a small number of servers
but
yeah so i
don't have much intuition there
okay
okay uh
yeah um
okay thank you for the talk alex uh
okay uh so
let's go to the next
uh talk yeah
okay
hey can you see my screen
yeah uh
yeah uh yeah it's cool uh do you wanna
make it full through yeah yeah yes okay
let me make the introduction uh
so hello everybody so this is just so
the presentation of our session by uh
sylvia
uh about the fastest boss matrix
inversion and the rec computation of
finance field okay
field okay say about each other
thank you so my name is silva casa
cuberta and i will be talking about
faster sparse matrix inversion and run
computation in finite fields and this is
joint work with rasmus king so let me
begin by just mentioning the two
arguably main problems in linear algebra
which are that of linear system solving
and matrix operation
so to begin with we have a clear
relationship between these two problems
namely if we directly compute the
inverse then we have a solver for linear
equations in a
moreover it was already shown in the
sixties by stressing that we can reduce
matrix inversion to matrix
multiplication
so that means that we
have algorithms to solve to invert the
matrix and to solve a linear system in
time of n omega where omega denotes
exponent of matrix multiplication
now these runtimes in linear algebra can
be misleading when we work in finite
position or arithmetic um if we're not
careful enough with the the bit size so
it's known that gaussian elimination is
not stable in finite precision
arithmetic and neither is conjugate
gradient in which if we if we take the
bit sizes into account then this
increase a whole other factor of n in
the runtime
so what can we do
well for example there's no instability
in finite fields so for example z model
p there's no round of error and in that
case uh this provides a simpler setting
for developing fast layer algebra
outcomes
but also there's you know there's an
interesting interplay between algorithms
in finite position arithmetic and those
in finite fields and it goes in both
it's beneficial in both directions so
there are instances of algorithms that
were developed in the reals and that
adapted in the finite fields or we first
developed them in finite fields and then
we make them numerically stable so
that's to motivate why we care about um
these algorithms occurring in finance
fields
so we can we can put in the table what
are the the current fasted run times for
the two problems i mentioned linear
system solving and make this inversion
in their um sparse versions and we
compare the finite field setting with
the finite position arithmetic
um one interesting open problem that was
open until last year was whether or not
you can solve sparsely or systems faster
than matrix multiplication in the finite
position or athletic setting and that
was answered in the positive by richard
payne and the impala and improved by c
penny um
this past year but it's still an open
question uh to know whether or not we
can also beat matrix multiplication time
in the problem of sparse matrix
inversion
so that's to give an overview of these
types of questions and now i'm going to
focus on this cell which is the runtime
that we improve so namely sparse matrix
inversion in finite skills and now i
will give a brief overview of the
construction of how we improve uh how we
obtain this runtime
so we begin by following the setup of
every little which is a algorithm we
improve upon
and um
following their setup we introduce
blocks so the input matrix a has size n
by n but to obtain better runtimes we
introduce blocks which are um of sizes
by s and then we have m of them so that
matrices are still size n by n then they
introduce a
block vector u which consists of the
identity matrix s
m times
um and basically they use this block
vector u to build two krylov matrices
with the input matrix a so these block
literal of matrices are obtained by
successively applying a to the to vector
u okay so you might be wondering why
we're defining those well the the key
insight in everybody else is that if you
multiply the input matrix a by these two
block rail of matrices on each side you
obtain a block angle matrix
and that's very good because it's very
structured so i think a matrix is a
matrix where each entry along the
diagonal transpose is repeated and in
our case it's blocked because u is a
block vector and so it's just the same
thing but blocks of size s by s
and so now we have managed to decompose
the
an arbitrary matrix a its inverse into
two parallel matrices which are very
structured as you saw and the inverse of
a block angle matrix and so another
question of inverting a becomes a
question of inverting a block angle
matrix
so now we focus on the inversion of
block structure matrices and i will do
this explanation with two blades
matrices just because the notation is
easier uh it's the same idea as a henkel
matrix except the the entries are
repeated along the diagonal instead of
the diagonal transposed
um so it's clear that that a toilet
matrix has a lot of structure
but what are the inverse well
unfortunately if you try a simple
example the inverse is not toilets but
we would hope that it still kind of
retains some sort of structure by being
the inverse of a place matrix
that's exactly the question that kailat
and al were asking in the 70s and and
made them introduce the notion of
displacement rank
so they said okay take a circle on
matrix z which is defined as all zeros
except this diagonal of ones
and the good thing about this matrix is
that when you apply it from the from the
left you shift your matrix down and that
becomes zeros
and when you apply it uh from the right
you you shift your matrix right and then
that becomes zeros
and so you can see that by the structure
of a tropicalis matrix um these all
become zeros when you subtract it from
the original one and so you get a round
two matrix
okay so that's not very surprising but
the very important thing of the paper is
that the same thing happens to the
inverse so if you apply the same linear
operator actually the dual we just need
to shift c transpose and z which was z
and z transpose here if you apply it to
the inverse of a tablets matrix you also
get a rank two matrix which is very not
obvious
and that's a general phenomenon so we're
going to call this a displaced matrix
means after we apply this operator and
the displacement rung will be the rank
of this displacement matrix
and so called al shows that the
displacement rank of a matrix equals the
displacement rank of the inverse and so
in the case of toe blades and henkel
matrices it's two in both cases
now in their paper they they also tell
us how to recover the undisplaced
original matrix from the displaced
matrix because this operator happens to
be invertible and so let me display this
theorem in a
in a picture which is clear so we have a
matrix then we apply the solution
operator we get the displaced matrix
which has displacement rank alpha and so
because it has this human branch alpha
we can express this matrix with alpha
vectors which we call generators
and then
tell us that if we want to go back to
the decompress like original undisplaced
matrix we take the entries in these
generators we place them in this
upper and lower triangular
torblades matrices so you see
again it's repeated entries and if we
perform these alpha sums and
alpha products and then we sum them
together we obtain the original matrix
um so that's how we go from displaced to
a displaced and this also really
generalizes to the block size in the
block size these vectors are size n by s
instead of n by one but still it's a
very succinct representation
okay so there's no inverse here and so
the actual question is
if you give me matrix a how quickly can
i find the rectangular generators of the
inverse
and bitmap and anderson gave an
algorithm um for that in subquadratic
time which also extends the block case
and so given a matrix a we find the
generators of the inverse
so now the question is once this
algorithm gives us these generators how
can we recover the inverse explicitly
and explicitly i mean writing down all n
squared entries
so let's go back to our setting where we
had a block angle matrix as i said all
this displacement
rank approach generalizes to totally
tangled under one kushi etc and so with
this bitmap and anderson algorithm we
can have the rectangular generators of
our our block angle inverse
but we want the angle inverse and so we
need somehow to go from these generators
to the matrices that we actually
want now the question is how fast can we
do that and that's where we bring up the
fast rectangular matrix multiplication
to multiply the compressed expression so
this rectangular generators x and y what
happens if we just multiply these
rectangular generators we take this
matrix which is unfortunately not the
matrix we want that's the matrix we want
if you remember for from the ul um
decomposition
however if we if we look at this matrix
you will see that each entry of the
matrix that we want corresponds to the
sum of all the preceding entries in the
diagonal of the matrix that we have
and so what we can do is we can use fast
rectangular matrix algorithms by legal
and ruthia to obtain this matrix and
then we build the matrix that we want by
traversing the diagonals of the matrix
that we have and filling up this matrix
in a kind of recursive dynamic
programming matter
and so for for each operator we can find
this this recursion that links its
matrices and takes only o of n squared
time
so the general scheme is we have our
block matrix that we want to invert
which is structured we use the bitmap
understand algorithm to find the
rectangular generators we use um fast
rectangular matrix multiplication to
multiply those and then we find we find
the appropriate recursive formula to
build back the undisplaced explicit
inverse matrix so his strategy is that
we stay to work with a compressed linear
expression for as long as possible and
um if you if you check the the theorems
that we have for for for this
construction we get subquadratic time
sorry quadratic time exactly for
inverting um a block ankle and toilet
blades um matrices for blocking factors
s up to up to a range and that's the
best we can do because just writing down
the matrix takes over n squared so
quadratic is the best we can hope for
so let's go back to our setting now that
we know how to invert the block angle
matrix we remember that we had the
expression um we had decomposed a
inverse into into this two karloff and
the explicit block angle matrix
so what remains to obtain a inverse is
just to apply
uh the block kyle of matrices this block
ankle inverse and we can do that
efficiently using corner scheme given
the the structure of this crowd of
matrices
and so that gives us the inverse of a
and um well we get an expression that
that i will get into but basically if we
optimize this expression for the block
size s that's where we obtain the final
runtime of um o of n to the 2 21 31 for
sparse matrices which uh yields the
fastest node runtime
and a very neat thing about this runtime
is that it only depends on it ends up
only depending on the value of
rectangular matrix multiplication
so
this black line corresponds to the
values the current values of fast
rectangular matrix multiplication by let
alone rutio and this black dot is where
um the runtime for sparse physics
inversion happens and you see that it
happens um
you know if this value is lower then the
value for sparse matrix inversion is
also lower
so we'll conclude with some remarks
after this overview of the construction
uh the main takeaways would be the
interplay between finite fields and
finite position arithmetic algorithms
and how we can have insights in both
directions
um the idea of decomposing arbitrary
matrix into structured ones such as
krylov and henkel
the use of displacement operators when
we work with structural matrices
and the use of fast rectangular matrix
multiplication when we work with these
compressed by linear expressions
and if you're interested you can check
the extended work on archive
and thank you very much for your
attention thank you also to the session
chair and to the organizers of itcs for
making the conference possible and now
i'm happy to take any questions
okay thank you for the talk serial very
interesting
feel free to um yourself or yeah
yeah go ahead if you have any questions
[Music]
maybe i have one question uh but maybe
it's a dumb question uh i'm uh i'm a
little bit confused like uh it seems to
me like
the algorithm didn't use the property
that the matrix is fast crucially i just
wonder like if the matrix is dense like
uh what what what will be the boundary
or like a well the argument will break
down maybe yeah
yeah it's a very good question i mean i
i cut the explanation of the of the
construction because it was only 10
minutes but basically um the sparsity is
crucial when we build
the krylov matrices and we build some
other matrices basically when you need
so let me go back um to
the first construction um
[Music]
which is here
if the matrix is dense
then you can't build these columns
efficiently um
the way they're built is by successively
applying a and when a is sparse meaning
it has like all of n non zeros then
applying it to a vector only takes o of
n but if it stands it will take off and
square it and so it then it becomes uh
too expensive to build this kind of
matrices in the first place
so you write that it does not affect it
does not affect the inversion of the
angle matrix like regardless of of a
being's part or dense you can't say
anything about the
the inverse of the angle matrix but you
needed to build kind of the matrices
that allow you to do this decomposition
but yeah that was it that was a real one
okay yeah thank you
uh yeah if there's no other question i
need to thank the speaker again and yeah
thank you so much
okay
the first talk
steve do you want to share your swing
you are muted
all right
okay uh yeah let me quickly introduce
you so hello everybody we will have the
fourth talk in this session by the uh
about uniform bonds for scheduling with
job science estimates
all right uh thank you so hi everyone
i'm steve i'm in this uh last year of my
phd at cmu and today i'm going to tell
you about some joint work i've been
doing with isaac rosoff and michael
mitzenmucker about scheduling with noisy
information and so
at a high level this work lives in the
world of algorithms with predictions and
specifically scheduling algorithms with
predictions so uh we've got a bunch of
jobs in a queue and we're trying to
decide which job to serve to minimize
average delay
and
and the type of predictions we're
working with are job size predictions so
it's generally good to serve short jobs
small ones ahead of large jumps uh the
idea is you can get something done uh as
quickly as possible and this is ends up
being good for average
um but this is hard to do when you don't
know how big job sizes are and so if you
have only noisy predictions of job sizes
so that's the problem we're studying and
one twist about this work is that we're
doing this all in a stochastic setting
so we're kind of taking a stochastic
first mindset there's like a sprinkling
worst case but mostly stochastic and our
motivation for this is that um lots of
computer systems in practice are well
modeled by stochastic arrivals and so we
hope studying the setting will give the
right insights for scheduling and
practice so
the question we're studying today is how
do we schedule to minimize delay with
noisy size estimates so let me start by
taking apart this question what do i
mean by scheduling and delay what sort
of uh
assumptions are we going to make on the
noise around the size estimates and
what do i mean by minimize what's a
reasonable goal to hope to achieve so
i'm going to answer all of these
questions um
in in today's talk so uh so let's start
with what are scheduling and delay so
basically what is the setting of our
problem so this is a single server queue
so this is a server it does some sort of
useful work this is a queue which holds
jobs waiting for service and this is a
job um it's i'm going to draw it as a
test tube whose height is its size the
amount of time it needs to be served and
so i'll represent that service as
filling the job with water
and so we can talk about the remaining
size of the job the amount of work left
or its age the amount that's been done
so far
okay and so we have these jobs
stochastically arriving over time and
i'll just flash the assumptions of the
arrival process the only one i want to
point out is this job size distribution
so each job size is generated iid from
some distribution but i'm not going to
make any assumptions about what this
distribution is it could be anything
which is important because in different
systems in practice they have very
different looking job size distributions
okay so this is our stochastic queueing
model so at some point the server is
going to finish this job when the job is
done its age equals its size it exits
the system the amount of time this job
spent in the system between arrival and
completion is called that jobs response
time so whenever i say delay i'm talking
specifically about response times
um so that job is gone the server's
empty what does it do next this is the
domain of the scheduling policy which
decides at every moment in time which
jobs serve and it does so preemptively
we can interrupt one job if we get bored
of it and start serving another one
um and we're going to assume no overhead
or other funny business when we preempt
okay so this is scheduling in the
stochastic queueing world and uh we're
trying to optimize delay so what does
optimizing delay mean well i told you
that delay is response time the time
between a jobs arrival and departure but
i've got a whole bunch of jobs arriving
to the system so i'm not just going to
look at one job's response i'm going to
look at the response time distribution
over all jobs in some very long arrival
sequence and this distribution will be
affected by the scheduling decisions we
make and so our goal today is to design
a scheduling policy that minimizes mean
response time or at least gets it as low
as possible um in some way so as a
warm-up how should we schedule if we
know job sizes exactly if there are no
no there's no noise at all and so well i
told you earlier that it's generally a
good idea to serve short jobs ahead of
large jobs the policy that takes this to
its natural conclusion is called srpt
shortest remaining processing time and
this always serves the job of least
remaining size in pre-emptive fashion um
so if a short job arrives it'll switch
to that short jump so that's if we have
perfect information what if we've got
noisy information so that's what we're
studying today so it when a job of true
size s walks into the system we as the
scheduler learn only a noisy estimate of
that z
and so what assumption are we going to
make about how z is related to s we're
going to assume that z is within some
constant factors of s so beta below and
alpha above
and i told you we're in the stochastic
queueing world and so these pairs of a
job's true size and estimated size are
going to be drawn from some joint
distribution
okay but other than assuming this beta
alpha bounded property i'm not going to
make any assumption about exactly how s
and z are correlated maybe for some size
it's always an underestimate maybe for
other sizes it's always an overestimate
and we're going to try and schedule in a
way that gets good mean response time no
matter what this joint distribution is
and in fact we're also going to try and
do it without knowing what alpha and
beta are so this is a sort of
semi-adversarial problem where we can
say an adversary is choosing the noise
model
it's going to be
beta alpha bounded but it's choosing the
noise model
and we without knowing the exact
distribution they chose without knowing
what alpha and beta are are going to try
and achieve good performance
and so that's the noise model we're
considering so what can we hope to
achieve in this
so this is algorithms with predictions
and so the kind of two main games in
town are consistency which is good
performance under low noise
and robustness which is good for
component good performance or at least
good enough performance under really bad
noise
and unfortunately it turns out you can't
achieve robustness at least not with
constant r in our setting
and so that we can't hope to achieve
good mean response time within the
constant factor of s or pt for arbitrary
alpha and beta so what could we hope to
achieve instead well we can still hope
for consistency but what if we have you
know alpha and beta they're not super
close to one but they're not super
terrible either what if we've got medium
noise
so we introduced a property which we
call g graceful degradation or just g
graceful for short
where a jobs approximation ratio is
bounded by some constant times a measure
of the estimation which in our case is
the ratio alpha over beta that's the
kind of natural measure of estimation
error and so we can hope for consistency
and we can still hope for g gracefulness
this sort of medium noise good
performance and i'll say that g
gracefulness is not a comple it's not
like it's totally new idea but it's
maybe a new ish idea to at least call it
out as being as important as consistency
and robustness so there is work that
studies uh g gracefulness sometimes
other other names sometimes it's called
robustness just makes it more confusing
but i think it's important to kind of
study these uh study this medium noise
setting as well and to start adding to
adding this to the set of things we
sometimes think about in algorithms with
predictions
okay so
uh what so we can hope for consistency
and gracefulness and that's exactly what
we achieve
we introduce the first scheduling policy
uh for the stochastic scheduling setting
that is consistent and graceful um so
the policy itself is new as is our
analysis of it
and something i'll point out here is
that this consistency result with c
equals one perfect consistency uh as the
noise decreases that's impossible to
achieve with worst case arrivals and so
that's an interesting fundamental
difference between stochastic scheduling
and worst case schedule um and so i
think it's exciting that we have both
kind of perspectives uh working on these
sorts of models at the same time
okay so in the last kind of two-ish
minutes of the talk let me give you a
bird's-eye view of what our policy is
and how we analyze it so i'm not going
to be able to like totally describe the
policy but at least be able to draw a
picture of it and so i'll start by
drawing a picture of srpt
as something that we call a rank
function so srpt is always serving the
job of least remaining size
so as a rep so what the rank function
does is it sort of encodes that
prioritization policy as a function so a
job walks in and its priority is going
to be its size and lower number lower
rank means better priority and so under
srvt as a jobs age increases its
remaining size decreases and it gets
better and better priority
so that's srpt's rank
so what we figured out how to do was we
figured out a rank function that
approximates srpt's rank function but
with only knowing z and without knowing
s
and so there was some trial and error in
generating this which i'll mention at
the end of the talk but we came up with
this policy which we call radical
because it kind of looks like a square
root sign vaguely um and it turned and
this is the policy that's consistent and
robust but
we don't it turns out to be really hard
to directly compare radical to srpt
and so what we do instead in our
analysis is we go via a third policy
called scale and scale is sort of
a direct sort of srbt but where the jobs
rank instead of starting at its true
size starts at an estimate size you
can't actually implement scale without
knowing true sizes so it's just a tool
for analysis but it turns out we can
compare radical to scale and scale to s
or vt
all right and i'll mention one more
thing about our analysis which is how do
we do each of these comparisons and this
is where the second sentence of this
talk comes into play i'm in the last
year of my phd so uh my thesis is all
about analyzing the performance of
scheduling policies in these sort of
sarcastic settings and expanding the
reach of what scheduling theory
and queuing theory can do and so there
are two main things in my thesis and i'm
excited about this paper because it gets
to use both of these things uh which is
the first time uh we've had to do that
so the first kind of piece of my thesis
called soap which we use to compare
radical to scale and then we use the
second piece of my thesis which is
called wine to compare scale to srpt so
these are both kind of new ideas from
queueing and one thing i'll mention is
that wine as i'll explain in the full
version of this talk on youtube um also
could apply in worst scheduling uh so
that's kind of what i want to highlight
that
all right so what did we talk about
today so we talked about scheduling with
noisy information we introduced a new
policy that has provably good
performance
and we've managed to do that proof by
combining these two new ideas from
queuing theory um and one thing i didn't
get to talk about today uh talk about in
the short version but what you find in
the full version of the talk on youtube
is why this problem is hard
and the reason this problem is hard is
because the first ideas that you would
think of for approximating srpt's rank
function turn out to have poor
performance
all right so that's what i wanted to say
today i'm happy to take questions or you
can get in touch
uh thanks for your attention
okay thank you for the talk and steve
so feel free to uh
mute yourself or leave your question in
the chat box
[Music]
so maybe i have one question to you so
you mentioned like
the problem is the fundamentally
different uh in the worst case right
like like you are dealing with the
stochastic setting and you say the
problem is extremely hardy okay can you
spare out that or like everything more
uh like a
uh so what is it so sorry so there are
no constant approximation for the worst
case yeah yeah
so yeah so i think in the worst case
setting um
they're
okay they're actually so the same group
uh published one thing and then they
publish just follow up so i forget the
exact state of the art but i think they
prove something that is a roughly
equivalent to our i forget if it's alpha
over beta or alpha over beta squared
factor so they basically prove graceful
degradation
so that is possible in the worst case
setting um
uh what isn't possible is this perfect
consistency it turns out you can't do
better than c equals two
in the worst case
um uh grace and
uh and yeah and another kind of
important difference is that the sort of
algorithm that you need to use in the
worst case is much more complicated
right here we have you know i can draw a
picture it's basically saying this is
how you prioritize a job over time and
that's enough for the stochastic case
there's still a lot that goes into the
analysis but the policy itself is very
simple and is sort of simple enough that
you could actually use it in practice um
and in the
yeah
cool yeah thank you for the yeah
thank you for the answer
okay
okay uh if there's no other question
let's thank the speaker gang
okay so so now it's the last talk by
um
do you want to share your screen
yeah
oh yeah can you see my screen
yeah yeah it's cool it's cool yeah okay
uh
yeah uh so yeah so uh so hello everybody
so so this is the last talk in this
session
uh by ash
about the counting and the sampling
perfect adventure perfect matchings in
regular expanding non-bipartite graphs
okay
okay thank you uh yes i'll try to finish
by 2 30. so hello everyone
um this is our paper on counting and
sampling perfect matchings and this is
going to work with farzam and shayan
so let's start with some notations
um let's say g is a graph with an even
number of vertices equal to 2n
i'm going to use m of i to denote the
set of all matchings containing exactly
i edges and little m of i is going to be
the cardinality of the set
and i guess um two two examples are when
i is equal to n we call these the
perfect matchings and when i is n minus
one we call them the near perfect
matchings
so uh take this graph for example it has
exactly two perfect matching so little m
of n is equal to two
and the main algorithmic task we're
going to be concerned with in this talk
is can we compute the number of perfect
matchings
it was shown by valiant that it's
sharply hard to do this computation
exactly so we are going to have to
settle for an approximate computation
and i guess one of the main
ideas that's been used for for this task
is is the following
um equivalence proved by germ valiant
and vazirani in much more generality
so the equivalent states that
the existence of a
efficient randomized approximation
algorithm for the number of perfect
matchings is equivalent to the existence
of an
approximate sampling algorithm from the
uniform distribution
over all the perfect matchings
and um here are two of i guess the major
results that have
used this equivalence so the first
result is by german sinclair
who gave efficient algorithms for i mean
who give mark of chain based algorithms
for the task on the right which gives an
efficient algorithm for the task on the
left as long as the ratio of the number
of near perfect matchings to the number
of perfect matchings is bounded by some
polynomial
the second result is by geram sinclair
and vigoda
who who give similar algorithms a markov
chain based algorithms that are um that
work in polynomial time uh if g is
vibrate without any more distributions
and let me just state that um we know
that there exists graphs even bipartite
graphs for which the ratio of near
perfect matchings to perfect matchings
is exponentially large
so uh it's not quite trivial to see how
many graphs kind of fall under the the
first result
and indeed this is a result that we are
going to be using later on in the
in this talk
uh and one of the biggest open problems
in the field is can we can we do these
tasks for any graph not just the ones um
tackled by by these results
okay and um
i guess our first result is that we can
do these for a certain class of graphs
which are the d regular expanded graphs
so let me define what an expanded graph
is
uh for simplicity let's just say that
the graph is d regular and let a tilde
be the normalized adjacency matrix
we know that uh
a tilde has a trivial eigenvalue of one
and we're going to say that the graph is
an epsilon spectral expander if every
other eigenvalue has magnitude of at
most epsilon
and for example freedmen proved that
almost every irregular graph has epsilon
which is around 2 over square root d
so now i can state our first result
which is if g is a d regular epsilon
spectral expander then there is a
algorithm for approximate sampling and
counting the perfect matchings that runs
in time n to the log d over log one over
epsilon um so to make sense of this
notice that if epsilon is small enough
compared to d or if d is a constant then
this is a
strictly polynomial time algorithm
and
in particular
using friedman's theorem we can prove
that this gives a polynomial time
algorithm for almost every d regular
graph
um
yeah i guess one one thing to note is
that these results should also hold if g
has all of its degrees in theta of d
as long as the specular expansion is
good enough
and
one caveat of this result is that we
require epsilon the spectral expansion
to be less than this this constant and
this is only achievable if d is larger
than some fixed constant
so in particular this theorem doesn't
say anything for
for three regular graphs
okay now let's switch gears and talk
about a different kind of result you can
prove about perfect matchings
so the van der waal in conjecture which
was proved by philip manning negotiators
says that if g is a d regular bipartite
graph then the number of perfect
matchings is at least d or e to the n
um it's natural to wonder whether you
can uh construct an analog for
non-bipolarity graphs of this theorem so
lowash in plum are conjectured that
something similar holds as long as d is
a d regular graph
that might not be bipartite but it has
edge connectivity of d minus one
which means the minimum cut is at least
t minus one
and
this theorem is this conjecture is still
open as of now and the best found we
know is uh
to show something like uh these kinds of
graphs have the number of perfect
matchings that is at least
1.001 to the end
ideally we would like to show something
similar like d or e to the n like
uh was the case in van der verden
conjecture
okay and actually we also know some
lower bounds for random regular graphs
and there's a result of bolobash and
mecca which shows that with high
probability with respect to the degree
the number of perfect matchings in
random regular non-bipartite graphs is
approximately d over e to the n
so here's our second result um
we show similar kinds of lower bounds
for d regular spectral expanders
um notice that the second term it's like
an error term which is going to be
negligible to the first term uh when
epsilon is small enough
so one can view our second result as
some kind of
special case of the lowest power
conjecture if you view
if you view
expanders as a special case of edge
connected graphs
and one can also view our result as a
kind of strengthening of volabash in my
case
so let me tell you the main ingredient
of our proof
the kind of inequality that we show is
that for for every k the number of k
matchings the ratio of the number of k
matching to the number of k minus 1
matchings is bounded by this quantity on
the right
and
um i guess for some intuition you can
plug in k to be n minus 1 and it gives
you that this ratio is bounded by n to
the log d over log of 1 over epsilon
and recall that this was exactly the
running time of our algorithm from
before
um
let me skip this and it turns out that
we can use this lemma to prove both of
our results
um
yeah i guess in the interest of time let
me also skip the uh
how these results are
from the lemma and let me tell you a few
things about how to prove this lemma
um so let's assume k is n minus 1 to
simplify the
dilemma
it turns out that this kind of uh
lemma has been studied before in
bipartite graphs by german sinclair and
some others
and
they show that the lemma can be reduced
to this other argument which says that
for any near perfect matching in the
graph
there is an there is a short orienting
path with respect to that near perfect
matching
um so if we can show the bottom lemma
for every graph that is a expanding
regular graph we would be able to prove
the level on the top
okay and recall that an augmenting path
for the this near perfect matching is
just a path that looks like this
um it turns out in the vibrate case we
can use a vertex expansion of
of this graph
um
along with a simple um alternating
breadth first search argument to show
that um
i'm not going to go through the argument
right now but we can use it to show that
there is a short indeed a shorter
winning path in this graph
and the main difficulty comes in the
non-bipartite case it's it's not so
clear how to uh emulate these arguments
in that case
and that's our main technical
contribution so um
we try to perform the same analysis the
easy analysis for the bipartite case on
a random bipartite subgraph
and that is uh
that is the key idea of our of our proof
so
we are going to construct a random
bipartite subgraph that that still
contains uh the matching m so as long as
we are able to show that the sub graph
has an augmenting path for m a short
amounting path for m this will also
imply that the original graph has a
short augmenting path for m
and this analysis is a bit tricky but we
are able to do it
and uh that uh that is how we prove this
level
um let me tell you about some future
directions to think of uh
two of the uh
two of the main directions that would be
interesting is whether we can prove
similar results with weaker expansion
guarantees so for example if
uh if the graph is only a one-sided
expander or if the expansion is closer
to one then then to 0.
and another conjecture is whether we can
prove something
using conductance of the graph instead
of specular expansion
uh
a third idea is maybe we can use this
this idea of random bipartitions uh
random bipartite subgraphs algorithic
algorithmically and maybe you can reduce
counting the number of perfect matchings
to counting the number of perfect
matchings in a random bipartition which
we can already do by gerund sinclair and
vikkora's algorithm
and
obviously the last feature direction is
the plumber conjecture
and let me just say that another
interesting
result we could get out of analyzing the
lowest plumber conjecture is potentially
better algorithms for
computing perfect matchings in the case
of d regular t minus one edge connected
graphs which would be uh pretty
interesting
okay um yeah let me stop there and thank
you to the chair and thank you for
everyone to everyone for listening
uh yeah thank you for the talk uh
let me ask you one
uh does anybody have any question about
uh for ash let me ask you one question
so as you you mentioned like
uh so you grabbed me if my understanding
is wrong like uh so so you so you
mentioned the conjecture in the last
page like the
like the m and m minus one dividing by m
n it could be something like into the
conductance which could be super
polynomial right yeah it could be
so so uh so then like it doesn't give
you the polynomial time algorithm
directive right it does not give you a
polynomial time algorithm for all graphs
so um these directions are just
exploring whether you can get polynomial
time algorithm for expanded graphs
okay so if i want if i won't get if i
want to
get a polynomial time algorithm like uh
is there any ingredients to to solve
that issue or like we should have a new
framework
um yeah it doesn't seem that that this
idea of bounding the number of uh that
this ratio of near perfect matchings to
perfect matchings is is going to get you
a polynomial time algorithm in all cases
so uh we know for sure that there are
many kinds of graphs that for this first
the ratio is exponential
um so yeah i think we definitely need
new ideas for the general uh for every
graph
okay thank you okay uh is there any
other questions okay uh
let's thanks all speakers okay i have a
okay sorry
yeah i i had a question
um so uh so you mentioned uh the idea of
like using the perfect the random
bipartition algorithmically um so
my first question was
so i guess my main question is so is
that part of the
uh algorithm that you use or is it only
part of the analysis right yeah i should
have said that so the algorithm we use
is the algorithm of uh jrm sinclair uh
right they they gave an algorithm which
works whenever the ratio of near perfect
matches
is bounded and all yeah like basically
all we do is we show that for this class
of graphs it is bounded
okay cool thanks
okay
okay so i think that's all the questions
for ash
okay so
okay so so uh let me thank all so let's
take all speakers and uh yeah and uh
thank everybody come to this session uh
we have uh so i i think we have five
great presentations uh this afternoon
okay so thank all the speakers
thanks
hey mark do you have anything to do do
you have do you want to say anything
thanks for sharing and uh
see you tomorrow uh
we're starting i believe 10 30 eastern
a little early pacific but
uh 10 30 eastern is uh session number
19.